[music]
[laughter]
only
professional war officers and
contract
recruits recruits take part in this operation, there is none and we do not
plan to do this now we  we hear
that it is necessary to make a no-fly zone on the
territory on the territory on the territory of
ukraine,
it is impossible to do this
on the territory of ukraine itself, it is possible only
from the territory of some neighboring
states, but any movement in this
direction will be considered by us
as participation in an armed conflict of
the side from whose territory there will be
threats are created for our
military personnel, we will immediately
consider them as participants in military
conflicts and dinner, no matter what
members they are, martial law
is introduced in the country in accordance with the law
by decree of the president and it must be
confirmed by the decision of the federation council in the
event of external aggression, including  including in
specific areas to conduct
hostilities, we have t  there is no such situation
and I hope death
[music]
glory to ukraine